Я є священник Православної церкви України.
Крім того, я є поліцейський полку патрульної служби поліції
особливого призначення "Київ" Судак Сергій.
(звучить молитовний спів)
Уже понад рік сержант поліції СергІй Судак щонеділі та по святах
править Службу Божу у прифронтовому Бахмуті.
Тут поліцейського з Краматорська знають як отця Сергія -
настоятеля храму Святого Феодора Стратилата. Єдиного храму ПЦУ
у сімдесятитисячному місті на Донбасі.
Ми як маргінали тут - теж можна так сказати,
тому що у церкви Московського патріархату тут є храми величні, гарні.
А ми служимо у підвалі.
Але й тут можна і молитися, і догоджати Богу, і причащатися,
і приймати святі таїнства. Так само це робили перші ченці у Києві.
Вони у своїх печерах молилися, і там були їхні храми.
(моляться за Україну та українських військовослужбовців)
Парафіян у бахмутській громаді ПЦУ - лише декілька десятків.
Їхніх пожертв не вистачає для будівництва справжнього храму.
Нині через коронавірус на богослужіння приходять одиниці.
Літургія для них - не лише релігійний акт.
Адже храм у підвалі - одне з небагатьох місць у Бахмуті, де вони
можуть поспілкуватися українською та побути серед однодумців.
Під час служіння тут згадується за всіх нужденних України,
за наших національних героїв, за білорусів,
які страждають через гоніння. Тут дійсно існує дух  не тільки власне
християнської православної церкви, а й дух України, її національної ідеї,
наших національних традицій, героїв.
Мене взяло обурення: чому українська церква повинна ховатися,
як партизани, в підвалі? А потім я подумала: якщо іншого місця немає
і якщо я не підтримаю свою церкву в підвалі, у нас її зовсім не буде.
Я спочатку ходила до московської церкви. За Україну там не молилися,
за наших воїнів, за державу там не молились.
Для мене це було неприйнятно.
Тому я почала ходити до цього підвалу, до нашої церкви.
У нас гарний священник український.
Щоправда, більшу частину тижня отець Сергій - сержант Сергій Судак,
поліцейський полку особливого призначення у Краматорську.
Замість ризи та кадила - уніформа та автомат.
Замість літургії - патрулювання вулиць та чергування на блок-постах.
Сергій каже, що полишити роботу в поліції наразі не зміг би,
навіть якби хотів. Адже прожити лише на пожертви парафіян
священнику Православної церкви України на Донбасі неможливо,
тож майже всі отці ПЦУ мають також мирські професії.
Хтось працює лікарем, хтось водієм, хтось - шахтарем.
Є навіть священник-оператор газорозподільної станції.
І там, і там я виконую свою службу.
Але все-таки у підряснику мені більш комфортно.
А як Вам зброю брати до рук - Ви ж священник?
Дійсно, священник не повинен брати зброю до рук, але оскільки в мене
така професія, мені як виняток це дозволили, тому що я зобов'язаний
носити зброю як поліцейський.
Оце наш пост.
Це колега мій, якого я міняю.
Як Вам служити разом зі священником?
Та нормально. Зато є кому гріхи відпускать.
Відпускає?
Буває.
До речі, якщо до Вас прийде людина, яка вчинила злочин,
у церкву на сповідь, Ви ж як священник не маєте розголошувати таємницю?
Так, я не маю права.
Якщо це на сповіді відбулося, то я не повинен це розповідати.
А якщо я дізнаюся з якихось інших джерел, то я повинен
це розповідати, я не повинен приховувати злочин.
До війни Сергій Судак жив у Луцьку, займався бізнесом -
торгував посудом. У 2014 році пішов добровольцем в АТО. А потім
лишився на Донбасі служити поліцейським. Каже, ще в молодості
мріяв стати священником. Навіть навчався у семінарії.
Вже у зоні АТО побратими питали: "А чого ти не можеш капеланом бути?"
Ну, так і сталося: зідзвонилися з місцевим архієреєм,
його високопреосвященством Сергієм, архієпископом Донецьким і Маріупольським,
і так він мене висвятив спочатку на диякона у 2016-му році.
Я не хотів далі висвячуватися на священника, але мене переконали,
тому що треба все-таки, тому що тут не вистачає священників,
і у 2019-му році на Віри, Надії, Любові мене рукопоклав мій архієрей
уже на священника. З того часу я вже служу в місті Бахмут в сані священника.
У Бахмуті, за 50 кілометрів від Краматорська,
на Сергія, крім парафіян, чекає дружина Оксана.
Вона - переселенка з Донецька, відома у Бахмуті проукраїнська активістка,
юристка та голова парафіяльної ради громади ПЦУ. Оксана планує
залишитися з чоловіком на Донбасі - розбудовувати українську церкву.
Регіон проросійський, тут дуже великий російський вплив,
російськомовний регіон. І тому українську церкву тут
небагато людей відвідує. Ми закликали, звісно, і благодійників,
і меценатів, щоб пожертвували гроші.
Ми навіть думаємо не будувати з нуля храм, а викупити якийсь
приватний будинок і його переобладнати під церкву,
як, наприклад, у Краматорську магазин переобладнаний під церкву.
Тут ніколи не було української церкви, розумієте?
І якщо ми будемо з такої точки зору оцінювати ситуацію,
то це дуже добре, що вона тут є.
Тим часом настоятель храму Сергій Судак планує продовжувати кар'єру
в обох напрямках - і в царині охорони правопорядку,
і в душпастирстві. Хоче отримати ступінь бакалавра
у Київській православній богословській академії. Каже, наразі
завершити навчання завадив карантин. А також планує
отримати звання офіцера Національної поліції.